[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabriel on commence
avec une visite ministérielle ministre
de la transition énergétique qui était
aujourd'hui à trappe oui vous l'avez dit
la ministre agè pagne runaché s'est
rendu à trappe pour l'inauguration de
l'usine pilote deramet cette usine est
destinée à tester le recyclage de
batteries de véhicules électriques une
étape avant de lancer la construction
d'une usine à plus grande échelle à
dunkererque aujourd'hui l'entreprise en
partenariat a avec le groupe Suez est un
leader européen dans les secteurs
miniers et métallurgiques pendant sa
visite la ministre a pu rencontrer les
salariés elle a notamment réaffirmé
l'importance de développer
l'indépendance stratégique et
énergétique de l'industrie française
ainsi que son approvisionnement dans une
démarche responsable on l'écoute l'enjeu
c'est notre planification écologique et
la manière dont nous allons développer
des solutions de mobilité électrique sur
le territoire des solutions qui soient à
la porter des Français et qui permettent
aussi de créer des emplois en France de
créer de la richesse en France et de
réindustrialiser notre pays tout en
renforçant notre indépendance
énergétique et notre souveraineté
économique bon un autre dossier où la
France souhaite s'améliorer le niveau
scolaire nos écoliers les derniers
résultats sont plutôt encourageants en
Île-de-France oui vous le savez
peut-être depuis 2017 les nouveaux
entrants en 6e sont soumis à une série
de tests au programme du français mais
aussi des mathématiques le but avoir une
idée du niveau de nos écoliers les
résultats de ces évaluations on été
révélés par nos confrères du Parisien et
devinez quoi Grégory les élèves de
l'académie de Versailles ont obtenu de
bons résultats seisssant au-dessus de la
moyenne nationale alors pour vous donner
quelques chiffres entre 2017 et 2023
l'académie de Versailles enregistre une
hausse de 6 points en français et de 4,5
points en mathématiques l'académie de
Versailles se classe donc 2e nationale
en français et c'est en mathématiqu on
vou revenir à présent sur un événement
qui est gravé dans la mémoire de nos
sapeurs pompiers ivelinois oui tout à
fait souvenez-vous en février 2023 de
séisme frappent la Turquie et la Syrie
face à l'ampleur des dégâts les
autorités turques font appel à l'aide
international parmi les 65 sapeur
pompiers franiliens mobilisés 13 sont
issus des casernes yvelinoises hier les
sapeurs pompiers du département ont
posté une vidéo recueillant les
témoignages de ces hommes et de ces
femmes pour cette opération je cite est
gravée à jamais dans la mémoire on
écoute un extrait de leur témoignage je
prends connaissance qui un séisme en
arrivant la caserne par qu'on me pose la
question on me dit tu es au courant
qu'il y a un séisme et peut-être qu'il y
aurait des équipes éventuell donc voilà
je la prends comme ça par hasard au
charge du matos et on part quoi et donc
on prend un moyen de un bus pour aller
effectivement sur Caraman marche donc on
descend avec le chef de la rescue le
Church et puis moi pour aller faire une
première reconnaissance et en fait là
c'est compliqué parce qu'on est appé par
tout le monde on est tiré de droite et
de gauche on essaie de rester le trinô
pour pas que qu'on se disperse en fait
ça crie partout ça nous ça cherche à
nous emmener partout et ces gens qui
pleurent et qui nous tirent pour qu'on
cherche à aller aider leur famille ça ça
glace un peu le sang et vous pouvez
retrouver leur témoignage et la vidéo en
intégralité sur la chaîne Youtube des
sapeurs pompiers des ivelines on termine
Gabriel avec une actualité plus légère
mais non pas moins sérieuse le
secrétariat du Père Noël est ouvert oui
je vous en parlais en début d'émission
le top départ et lancé pour envoyer vos
lettres au Père Noël créé en 1962
l'opération a été mise en place par la
poste alors grégoryie si vous souhaitez
envoyer votre lettre vous avez deux
possibilités sous la forme manuscrite en
adressant votre courrier au Père Noël
sans oublier d'indiquer votre adresse ou
alors de manière informatique sur le
site de la Poste vous avez jusqu'au 20
décembre et bonne bonne nouvelle les
lutins répondent en français et en
anglais dans le département des boîtes
au lettes vont être installé à La
Verrière par exemple ce sera dès le 27
novembre à plaisir vous pourrez déposer
vos courriers dès le 1er décembre je
vous conseille de vous rapprocher de vos
communes pour en savoir plus je sais pas
si j'ai été assez sage cette année et
vous pouz Esser je vais essayer aussi en
tout cas merci pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les evvelines n'hésitez pas
à la partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag news